well I'd fallen in thrall to the whole
Stephen Hawking icon as a man and for as
the profundity of his idea is back in
1988 when he released the groundbreaking
brief history of time but sort of I know
for me personally I woke that doorman
pardon you that doesn't really want to
ask the big questions but he went
straight there and he had 10 million
people asking you know why are we here
how does the universe begin and so forth
and I thought someone's gonna make a
movie about this guy
sometime I'm never thinking I would have
any role to play and then fast forward
to 2004 and I came upon Jane Hawking's
autobiography and similarly Eureka
moment this fascinating complex private
life and I thought if I could marry that
incredible character that was Stephen
Hawking with the incredible courage and
determination and strength of Jane we
would have I thought a unique cinematic
story yeah I mean I think we would all
say the sort of the scariest thing that
could possibly happen in your life would
be that somebody would say we're gonna
make a movie about you and your family
and the intimate details and certainly
you know behind the closed doors and
their domestic life so it her fear was
very warranted I think it's just a
terrifying idea and and I think what was
the biggest struggle with Jane in a way
is that is going sort of from the
literal of each thing that happened and
what was said and what somebody was
wearing and what room they were in to
being able to take those 25 years and
put them in a what we sort of sometimes
described as a two-hour poem about your
life you know it's not gonna be exactly
literal because it's impossible to do
that and that kind of time frame and it
Anthony had already laid down the trust
experience I mean the trust relationship
with her and then we spent a lot of time
explaining sort of the type of movie we
would make and that we were obviously
not going to exploit them in any way and
that they were heroes to us and that
they're the main thing that I kept
harping on was that she was such a hero
of mine because I I found her a bill
to jump off this emotional cliff with
this man when he's given to your death
sentence just profound I I thought it
was just a profound love story I always
say it's one of the greatest love
stories of our time I think how did you
prepare your body to do those to do
those things it felt almost like you
would have to be split brain one brain
the actor but you also your body also
had to act as well my only instinct what
I still find so weird about acting on
film is that there is no specific
process or way and I tend to approach
each role afresh and try and create some
sort of method or process but my
instinct with this was that that
everything would affect everything so
anything that I was doing physically
would have ramifications on what the
costuming was which would have
ramifications on what makeup was being
so I started by with James we found an
extraordinary group of people and um one
of whom was a dancer I asked to work
with a woman called Alexandra Reynolds
and I spent about four months James and
Lisa gave me time and Felicity time and
I spent about four months going to an LS
clinic in London and meeting with the
specialists there and being introduced
to many people suffering from this
hideous disease and and their families
and they invited us into their home's
many of them and so seeing the physical
ramifications but also the well really
the emotional ramifications too and
what's interesting about ALS or MND is
that you have what are called up and
neurons and lower neurons and if the
upper neurons go there is a rigidity
like a spasticity and if the lower ones
go there is like a wilting and airless
is a mixture of those two but which
parts of your body have which is
completely unique to each person so
unfortunately there's very little
footage of Steven before the 80s in fact
none that I could find when he's already
in the chair so I basically took all the
photos I could and took it to the
specialist at the Ellis clinic in London
and working with her like photos like
the wedding photos when Steven and Jana
holding hands you actually see that his
hand is leaning entirely on her but but
there's a wilting quality so she helped
me
work out what she thought the decline
was specifically and then with Anthony
Anthony then wove the specifics of that
into the script and we we then I then
worked with the dancer to try and kind
of train those muscles because when we
shot we didn't shoot chronologically
till we had to kind of jump into these
different physicality so that when we
were Felicity and I were playing
together we could just have that the the
human and the emotional story because
that was always what struck me certainly
about Anthony's scripts so you did not
shoot this sequentially no no I think I
think these Suren James looked into it
but as always you guys don't learn it
was economically unviable unless your
boyhood so in any given day you could be
at various stages of the disease in any
given day of shooting our first day God
remember it so clearly got to four
o'clock in the morning the night before
we started filming this was months of
prep I was so scared and I hadn't slept
and it got to four o'clock in the
morning and I was being picked up at
5:30
I had to saw this sort of melatonin next
to my bed and I was like do I take it
like how can I possibly start day one of
this film without a nice little moment
sleep because on that first day we
started with the the scene in which
Felicity and I spinning round Stephen
and Jonas Mira in the morning and then
at lunchtime um he was on two sticks and
then in the afternoon he was in that the
second wheelchair so the first day was
where's the trial by fire put it that
way and and fortunately I think one of
the scenes was quite emotional so the
fact that I hadn't slept after putting
your body in that those positions how do
you come out of it I just imagine you
had physical therapists or massage
people to kind of get Eddie back I did
part of that process in the four months
before was the idea of training with the
dancer was so that those muscles
wouldn't be shocked into kind of into
that situation but would be there would
be a comfort in it and and and what I
love about dancers is they go they do it
again and again and again until it's
right and that was that was it's like in
the theater you know it was a similar
sort of deal but no I went to a very
brilliant
osteopath and for the whole prep and
then into while we were filming and
occasionally there would be a cry and
he'll acupuncture it's helpful technique
Eddie and I both have a very similar
approach to filmmaking and one that
comes from working in the theatre we
both worked with a director theater
director called Michael Grandage in
London at the Donmar Warehouse and and
we tried to apply a lot of those
practices that we learnt in the theatre
into the film so having lots and lots of
time to prepare and rehearsal doing
scenes over and over again running them
trying different things out doing as
much research as possible so so as Eddie
said we went and met carers met patients
and and I think when you feel like
you've done the preparation it means
that when you come to set you can be
free to be spontaneous on the day and
and I think a chemistry is always a
strange that you never get something you
can't really explain but but I think the
particular chemistry was this is Eddie
and I have a huge amount of respect for
each other and and it really felt like
James gave us time before we started
shooting we we met for five months
before and and it was a very open
dialogue between the three of us so that
we we felt very comfortable by the time
we were in front of a camera I'm curious
about your time with Jane Hawking too I
mean without sayings I think what she
said to you but I'm curious about when
you met her and you know some of the
conversations you had and just the
feelings that you know she shared with
you I was really intimidated because I'd
read Jane's book which the which the
film is is based upon and I just thought
this woman is a saint she's incredible
you know I sort of felt like I should
bow down to her when I saw her but she
was very welcoming she invited Eddie and
I both over for dinner and I went round
and just chatted with her
length she was very open about talking
about their relationship showing she
showed us both photographs of when they
first met she had bought clothes the
church that she had preserved her
wedding dress that she'd just preserved
beautifully from when they were married
which shows you how much that
relationship meant to her but actually
so much of it was just a you know
observing her and I felt a little bit
disingenuous sometimes because I'd be
sort of nodding and talking to her but
just watching what she was doing you
know watching how she was picking up a
teacup and she has this variable etic
movement she loved dancing and I thought
well that'll be interesting to put into
the film while I'll experiment with that
and actually worked with a really great
movement coach for the Guildhall School
of Speech and Drama in London and
discuss things like you know how to age
someone from the age of 20 and how your
body changes through to when you're 40
and then working with a dialect coach
which which Eddy and I just you know
loved having the opportunity to to work
with these experts who really helped us
inhabit the part I understand that the
voice box that was used here was is it
Stephens voice so what happened is um
Stephen owns the copyright to his voice
and just good to know their place but so
when we made the film we we made an
approximation of his voice so a
synthesized approximation which is what
we use as we were shooting live but then
after seeing the film Stephen gave us
his voice and and that was there were
various things actually I was just
remembering that the the medal the
companion of Honor medal in the last
scene with Stephens and he let us use
that thisis the signature on thesis
that's actually his yeah so there were
various things but the voice was just
for us particularly if you're you know
there were moments I had all of Stephens
documentary material on an iPad it was
days of sitting in front of the mirror
trying to replicate that and and and
failing but if you're always aspiring to
get to that truth
what was amazing is when you're given
his voice and there really was a shift
and change to the film when that
happened you're just that inch closer to
getting to that truth that you'll never
quite attain but I realized actually
it's a combination of American accent in
Swedish and then which makes it and we
couldn't get the Swedish party you know
they're Swedish about say that they told
in the Stockholm well it's kind of
random for them we would know the mind
of God that it's I think that's why we
couldn't get it we could have just got
you to do